Okay, guys, in this episode, we're going to be looking at February back
testing for 2024.
And the preceding videos will essentially just be us back testing the rest of
trading specifically this intraday m15 bias model.
So if you do see me referring to the screen on my left, I do have trading
view up on this screen.
And the reason behind that is, is the, unfortunately, at this moment in
time, FX replay doesn't have kind of like an economic news indicator to
indicate, you know, what news events are occurring and when.
So when I'm back testing, maybe you'll take this for yourself.
Um, I'm just looking at trading view.
So I'm going back to the date on trading view and just understanding what
news was there for that specific day, right?
So, okay, you can see my screen, what we're going to do is start from scratch.
So we're going to start back testing and to do that, we're going to
essentially just start a completely fresh back testing session.
So what you want to do is you want to create back testing sessions.
I'm going to take you into here and then you can name it the session name.
So for me, it's going to be, you know, um, 2024 SMC intraday m15 bias model.
Right.
The description is pretty simple.
Just testing this model in 2020.
Before we're going to connect to the m15 intraday bias model playbook so
that it's going to track everything related to that playbook.
Now, whether you're trading FX or whether it's a, you know, you want to be
testing out in futures, so be it futures being six E or FX being, you know,
just standard Euro USD, that's up to you.
For the purpose of this video, I'm just going to test in Euro dollar.
And for the starting balance, we're just going to put a million dollars,
which is the goal that many of you should have when it comes to, you know,
your funded accounts, especially with futures pro firms.
It's never been easier to get this amount of money and the management
requiring obviously strict discipline following your rules, appropriate risk
management, et cetera.
But I truly believe that a million dollars is really not that difficult.
I mean, just seven apex accounts, 150 k apex counts will take you to a million
dollars.
Um, and I don't really think that's difficult to pass as long as you kind
of understand how to gain the system.
So start date.
We're going to start in 2024, I'm going to start February, my trading year
typically starting in February, uh, for the most part.
Maybe sometimes second week of January, but kind of predominant focus is
coming at the beginning of February.
And then we're going to pretty much also not be looking to trade in December's
price action as well for a multitude of reasons.
Number one, price action just becomes really choppy and difficult to trade.
We have holiday, so a lot of institutions are packing up for holidays,
which makes the market a lot less kind of predictable and again, more
choppy and just personally, like after a great year of trading, um, it should
be a goal, you know, we're not working a job.
We're not working for somebody else.
We want to have the freedom to live our life.
And so for me, you know, I want to be using December to go away, go away, spend
some time with family, go and reflect on my year, plan the next year.
And I need that kind of time to, um, reflect and, you know, kind of reset
essentially after a hard work in year.
And so I want to tailor this to the reality of, you know, how it is that I'm
actually going to trade and maybe you'll trade the same way.
So first of February, um, it doesn't really matter what the day.
We're going to end this test December the first, so pretty much the end of
November,
December the 1st, 2024.
Uh, that's just the full year.
So it's a 10 month year from February all the way to, you know, the beginning
of December.
And then again, like I said, December, I want to kind of take that time,
reflect
and spend some time with family, enjoy the kind of, you know, reap the rewards
of a hard work in year.
And then for January, it's a little bit similar in some sense.
I mean, it's my, my birthday right at the beginning of January.
So I'm usually, you know, kind of enjoying my birthday right at the beginning
of January.
Um, and then, you know, kind of getting back into things second, we could
January after the new year, after Christmas, after my birthday.
So this is kind of realistic trading for me.
Um, so yeah, I guess we'll just kind of jump straight in and create session.
Now, when you get in here, it's going to look like this, right?
There's going to be a lot of kind of ugliness in some sense.
So first and foremost, I'm always deleting the, um, a volume indicator.
There's always this sign in here.
I just kind of try to move it to, you know, an area where I don't need to look
at it.
Cause I just don't want that popping up, although it just pop up every time you
're into a position.
Uh, for now, we're going to X off this journal.
And this is kind of what you're going to see.
So what I like to do is preset my charts.
I'd like to have my charts, um, how I want them at this time and time.
For some reason they don't have, uh, oh, sorry, I don't like, no, I do.
I kind of want to save my previous charts, just the chart layout itself.
So if you go into the chart, you customize it and then you template it.
Um, and then it should let you kind of add to template.
So I've added this to my template.
So this is my template that I currently use.
Um, but we do need to be adding our session indicator.
Right.
So, uh, trades that I'll have their own session indicator.
And again, I like to have mine specifically set to, you know, how exactly I'm
going to be, um, using it colors and everything.
So what you can see is everything is in UTC.
So we want to have our sessions specifically in UTC.
So what you can do is you want to make sure that it's absolutely correct is,
you know, we can.
Um, whereas, what's the time section?
Hmm.
That's odd.
It's midnight.
So right now it's set to UTC minus four.
Ah, my mistake.
Um, cool.
So yeah, same thing again.
I always have my, um, my key tools just favorited.
And then I have my favorite box down here, just a slight, um, just a.
Slight improvement on my workflow.
So I want to make sure that all this is correct.
So first things first, just the colors, right?
At this point, you already know that my New York session is always orange.
My Asia session is blue and my London session is green.
So that's first.
And so that green into the remark.
So that's first and foremost.
So now I have my colors.
I also don't like to have it's a different green.
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
Cool.
I also don't like to have these lines on here.
So you can just go and X out those lines, personally, just doesn't really help
me.
So now we have our inputs.
So what we basically observe and it's always, you know,
strict to UTC.
So what you can do, if you want to make sure that it's completely accurate,
can head over to something like chat, GPC and give it the context.
So for example, you know, um, for example, it's simple as if my Asia session.
If my Asia session is, um, APM to midnight EST.
So it's done the time always the same.
I'm just simply ask it, if my Asia session is APM to midnight EST standard time
,
what was that time in UTC on February the first?
And it would tell you, so, um, it was UTC minus five.
And sometimes you'll have a little bit of annoyance with this.
You can see here UTC minus four is New York, but actually it's observing UTC
minus five.
That does happen.
I think trade in view auto changes it.
Mm.
So it's pretty much always like that.
I still haven't figured out.
Um, so it's going to be one a M UTC.
So because the indicator is observing UTC, the inputs are going to be UTC.
So I'll just change the time to UTC right now.
For example, I can see that this is actually midnight when in actuality, it
should be one a M to five a M.
And so right now what I have is one a M, I have midnight to five a M.
So this should be one a M.
So my Asia session needs to be like that.
And then New York is seven to 10 AM.
London is two to five AM.
All right.
And it's going to give me the actual accurate details that you don't need to
worry about confusion.
So seven AM to 10 AM is London.
So that's already set.
Right.
We have seven AM to 10 AM and then 12 to three is New York.
So that should be that.
And so now what I can do is if I go to UTC minus four, you'll see it's eight
till midnight.
It's still seven to 10.
And so I don't really know under somewhat trade of you do here because they
have
UTC minus four as New York, but I'm pretty sure the ease and standard time was
observing
UTC minus five during this time period.
And so I think trade of you just also changes it anyway.
Don't need to kind of get into details.
That's accurate.
Right.
I have my sessions.
I have everything.
And so now that I'm actually set up, I can essentially begin trading.
These details are going to become important later.
All right, so for now, just I wouldn't really worry too much about them.
So first things first, do we have any news?
We have ISM at 10 AM Eastern Standard Time.
And we have inflation rate at five AM.
So the end of London, we have inflation rate.
And at the end of New York, we have ISM manufacturing.
So I know that got it.
So now it's a case of what's my, what's my bias, right?
How do we look from a structural perspective?
So you can see, obviously we're being aggressively bullish.
I don't need to go into all the details and try to mark the exact highs and
lows because the reality is is, you know, I can come to the relevant price
action, understand the highs and lows if you just go to relative price action.
So I can already tell, for example, like, obviously number one, when we took
this
low, we were bearish.
Now I can just go into this price action.
And this price action is going to give me, you know, the indication of what the
structure was.
And even in here, I can already see that there was a pullback and continuation
and shift and continuation.
So I don't need to look at all this price action.
Because I just know that there's definitely some kind of pullback, right?
From at least this low to that high, which got broken.
And then this low put in this high and then we kind of broke back down.
So I don't need to go hunt in all the way.
You know, three years ago, it's fine.
My M15 structure, like it's totally fine like this.
So then I understand that that was the swing high.
And now we're still observing that same price delivery.
So swing high, you can see we liquidated the swing high, right, straight away.
So we liquidated the swing high, we traded away from liquidated swing low, but
we're
still bearish.
So we're still observing bearish price action.
So now I can begin and kind of proceed to trading my New York window.
Let me just make sure that these are accurate, customised settings.
So next session.
So this is New York time, right?
So the session indicators are UTC, but the actual session times are in New York
.
So you can see here, I have start up and then session at 2 AM, start up New
York
session, which is New York time at 7 AM.
So what that allows you to do is kind of just skip to the relevant price
action straight away.
So you don't need to just play, bar replay, bar by bar.
So now everything is set up.
Now we can look at trading.
So we're bearish, right?
First and foremost, we're bearish.
So I'm looking for shorts.
OK, I also want to sync this to time frame so that whatever I play is relative
to that.
One kind of forward, sync to time frame.
Cool.
So London session is opening now.
And now we're taking out these lows.
So now we've actually broken structure to the downside.
So now my high is up here.
This is my swing high and my swing low isn't yet confirmed.
I just know that we're bearish.
OK, gain liquidity, and I'm not interested.
This is just purely intraday.
So now that London session is finished and there was literally nothing.
So now it becomes a case of, let's go to New York session.
So here's New York session.
So we have Asia session high here, which I'm observing.
I want to see a run on that high.
OK, we get the run on that high, which is awesome.
Can we see a lower time frame shift?
So this is the first month.
This is one of the models, which is the New York sweeps Asia pro trend.
And we'd look in now for our lower time frame confirmation.
So this doesn't give me that confirmation objectively
because it just liquidates it.
So the actual M1 structure is this one law.
And the time is 9 a.m.
So we do have ISM.
So you don't want to be in a trade.
We'd be that close to ISM to talk down to you.
And yeah, this is going to be another trade day.
It's 942.
And there's ISM, right?
Nothing. OK, so now we can just go to the next day of London session
and just observe what happened. OK, cool.
So now we're right up in here by this swing high.
So now we have our swing low, which is confirmed to be this London law to our
swing happier.
So we're looking for short, straight away.
Today is Friday the second, so we have NFP.
Again, on NFP days, price action is a little bit more difficult to
is NFP, right? Yeah, so price action is a little bit more difficult to, you
know, trade in some sense.
But here we are.
We have Asia session high
right in here, and that's already been swept in Frankfurt session.
So we need to kind of go and look at this.
What's happened in the lower time frame?
So we have a sweep in Frankfurt.
All right, I have a little bit of a look of our structure.
Cool, cool, cool.
So I can see that this is my M1 low, so sweeping Frankfurt, maybe London
continuation is possible.
So we just wait to see aggressive bullish reaction off of that.
So London opens up a sweep on Frankfurt.
And at this point, we're pretty much good to trade providing that we stay below
this high.
So we're just looking for a lower time frame shift.
And that lower time frame shift at this time and time would now be below this
law.
OK, that doesn't give us anything.
That's not three candles.
OK, we shift the highs.
So a new low becomes down here.
We have now taken that M15 high, albeit a liquidation.
So could technically still sure that price action, but we have traded above
that high.
OK, that becomes entry confirmation.
So now we can look at trading this.
Now, where do you trade from?
So we're also a five minute time frame, which is usually when you have a large
expensive range of this, I'm usually looking at the five minute time frame.
And I'm looking at this final buy to sell.
This final buy to sell that changed character, that's going to be my entry.
So I can go on here.
I can set a short position for my stops at this high, 7.1 pips.
And then how are we managing this trade?
So again, I don't want to be the one swinging for the fences down here.
So we want to be looking at past and our profits across the board.
So let's kind of have a look.
So obviously, first and foremost, we're going to open this position.
So we can go order, we've got advanced order, current balance, 1%.
So this is a 1% risk limit order with a star plus with a profit target.
So if I just click that, it's going to automatically kind of set that limit for
us.
But where do I, where's my 5R?
All right, my 5R is here.
So when we hit this level, I want to close a decent amount of this position.
And then I may want to close another decent amount of the position.
When we hit this next area, where there will be orders.
And then, yeah, we can go to the lows down here.
So I have three different targets in mind.
If this plays out, we'll go to the five minutes, you can have things play out.
So it is 3.5.
We have more than enough time.
That is a tag, OK.
And that is a stop us.
So stops get hit.
So that's a, that's a first trade taken, right?
And it takes up a loss.
So now what we need to do is in our journal here, I don't need to input all my
notes
for every single session, which is not necessary.
I'm doing it live and recording.
We are recording, right?
Yeah, but what we can do here is trade notes.
So this is the trade that's just been taken.
Now I can open this trade and now we can start organizing.
So you can see here we have playbook.
So was the M15 pro trend?
Yes.
OK, was we in a strong point of interest or session liquidity sweep?
Yes, because we swept Asia, right?
We swept Asia with Frankfurt, we swept this old high.
So we have a liquidity sweep.
Did we have an M1 change of character?
Yes.
Did we trade from an M1 to M5 or the block of ever again?
Yes, we did.
All right.
And then management.
Breaker protected structural law that I entered from.
So this was a protected structural law.
We've broken it, so I'm out.
No trading on session with CPI.
Don't didn't enter before retail sales or call PC.
So great.
I followed my playbook.
That's a valid trade.
Cool.
Now we can start to hagging.
So what set up was this, right?
Was this a discretionary trade?
No, this was a.
This was a.
Done, done, done, done.
So it wasn't New York, sleep London.
Oh, no, wasn't, it wasn't a description.
It wasn't Frankfurt sweeps.
So it was technically London has only been swept.
So I guess it's actually technically.
So this is technically.
London sweeping Frankfurt.
So I don't want to consider this as a London sweeping.
Asia.
So what I need to do here is I need to add a quick tag.
So tags.
We're going to add a quick tag and tag going to be set up.
So the name of the tag is going to be London sweep Frank, right?
And this is essentially where.
London session sweeps Frankfurt after after Asia sweep.
So Frankfurt was already swept Asia and then London goes and was that added to
ourselves should be.
So that's when, yeah, London sweeps Frankfurt, let's continue.
London sweeps Frankfurt.
Tradeness.
So that's going to be playbooks already added.
Yep.
So okay, cool.
So it's going to be.
London sweep Frank.
That's going to be London sweep Frankfurt, the point of interest.
Now, were we trading from a point of interest at this price point, right?
Was there an M15 point of interest?
Well, after the sweep of the highs, whole trading from a point of interest.
No, we're not trading from a liquidation.
So point of interest is empty, right?
We're not trading from an actual point of interest.
We're just trading from a liquidation session.
It's a London session trend.
Okay, so what portion of the M15 trend are we in?
So we look at the M15, we can see that we were, you know, um, you can see the
middle of them.
Uh, we changed character down here.
We had a continuation in here and then we had another break of stretch down
here.
So at this point, we are trending, right?
We've had a change of character plus break of structure plus break of structure
.
So we're trending.
Cool.
So the structural flow, we are obviously at pro X, but you know,
there isn't really any internal, although it is a huge price leg.
There isn't actually any confirmed, um, internal structure, right?
There's no internal three kind of over from high to low.
Another reason, so it's simply just void, right?
It's just, uh, we are trading in premium discount.
Yes, uh, news, no news, right?
And then execution window.
So we executed this trade.
If we go to the five minute timeframe, basically the trade at exactly.
Let's make sure it's accurate.
So we actually have the trade at 401.
So this is the four to five AM.
Window. And so now my tags have been organized.
So now I've organized this trade, right?
If you want to take a screenshot of this trade and write notes and stuff as
well,
when you're testing yourself, that's totally fine.
That's something you can absolutely do.
Um, maybe that's something, you know, that will help you.
You can do audio recordings, whatever it is, or speech to text, whatever it is.
I haven't used it.
Um, but yeah, for me, just not necessarily cool.
So we have, um, that trade detailed.
Now we can move on.
I don't know where my indicator is gone.
I'm not going to have to go all the way back.
Do I have a safe preset?
Um, okay.
I'm ready to sort that out.
So UTC, one to five, one to five London session, seven to 10, 12, two, three.
And then colors.
I need to save this as my pre, my default.
I think sometimes as well in each session, it changes.
Uh, Asia is always blue.
London is always green.
Cool.
If I go here now, save as default.
Not sure if that'll do in the future.
Cool.
So London session has finished and now we have a change of character.
So now the M 15 is bullish and we understand that, you know, we're not really
going
to be getting so trade and we also have a New York session and we have NFP.
So we're not going to be trading NFP.
What did I just click?
I just click on the session.
It's fine because we're not going to be trading NFP anyway.
So what we end up getting actually is pretty much just a sweep of these highs,
although, yes, you know, it did break in clothes, change of character.
Really, it was just a sweep of those highs to trade a lot of prices.
So we had our direction on point, but we just got liquidated beforehand.
Um, then you can see we have a change of character.
So the M 15 is indeed bearish again.
Uh, if we look at this, you can see there's no free kind of pullback.
Uh, one to now we have a three kind of pullback.
So this is confirmed as our swing law.
So we're already above Asia and so we'll kind of see how London session trades.
So we are looking to trade short and doubly, um, Frankfurt as well.
It's Asia.
So we come in here and we look at Frankfurt's behavior.
We're going to come to the M one real quick and see swing high, swing low.
So the swing, so the M 15 structure is the same, not the same.
Sorry, um, M one swing low is the same as our M 15, which means to get a change
character, we'd need to get a structural continuation.
So in this sense, um, you know, we, we really don't need to be looking at
trying
to, to trade this, uh, then you can see we sweep Frankfurt.
So now that we sweep Frankfurt, we can look again.
And now what we can see is that actually we get a one minute breaker structure,
our change of character and then another one minute change of character to the
cell side.
So now we could be looking at shorts, but the problem is, is the moment that
this
logo is taken out, that becomes invalidated.
So we can look at shorts.
Um, but if I was to be shortened, again, large price leg, looking at M 15, I
would
really be looking at this fair value gap, but I'm going to play a couple
candles.
Cause if we break this low, it's invalidated.
I want to put all the entry on all that sort of stuff.
If it's just not needed.
So we sweep the low and then we break below the law.
So now this trade becomes invalid for me personally.
Um, and so now we have a swing high up here and a swing low down here.
Right.
So we keep playing price.
It's now the Monday, the 5th of February as well.
By the way, so Monday, the 5th of February, what do we have today?
We have a balance of trade at two, which is already finished.
And we have ISM, uh, at 10.
So it's four AM, probably not going to get anything from a London session.
Let's just go ahead and go to New York session.
So New York session opens.
Right, our swing high is up here at this age, a London session high.
Um, you can see here that we have.
So pullback, nope.
So we continue in our bearish room, probably not going to get a trade.
Um, on this day, cool.
So now we go to our next day.
Our next day is due to the sick for fair.
So choose the sick for fair, but we have no news, um, for this day.
So we're all clear to go.
Now, we're already above Frankfurt, right?
Already above, uh, already above Asia, sorry.
So Frankfurt has already swept Asia.
Um, and our M one structure.
So we can see the.
Frankfurt has also changed character.
So what we'd need to see for London, if we wanted to trade this is a
continuation
lower and we don't get that.
So we end up continuing to trade higher, right?
I don't need to sit on the one at time frame because I can read the one minute
from the five minute.
So we continue trading higher, um, have a little bit of a breakdown there.
Does that give us nope?
Cool.
No change of character.
So done.
That would be our change of character.
It is 353.
So that's a set up confirmation, a five minute time frame.
If I wanted to get involved in the position, I would look at the five minute.
I see this cluster here, 15 minute gives me an actual confirmation.
So I'd really be looking at just this entire cluster here.
So from this high really to this low, if the risk reward makes sense, right?
That would pretty much be my set up.
And then I just want to stop at this high in here.
Um, and then the swing low is going to be down here.
It's going to give us a one to five extra water.
So that'll be the trade.
I won't enter the trade until price starts coming back up towards us.
And we continue selling off and that's five.
So no entry in that trade either.
Now we can move to New York session.
Cool.
So New York session and quite clearly see we have equal lows down here.
We're still bearish.
So we're still looking for shorts.
See if New York session can give us anything.
Um, that's nothing for me.
And no, so literally nothing from New York session as well into the next day.
That takes us into the seventh of Feb.
So seventh of Feb, no news again.
Cool.
So 15 minute timeframe, we're still bearish.
So our swing high is up here and our swing lowers at these equal lows.
All right.
Well, they actually look at that low.
So we've got a low down here.
Cool.
So we're looking for shorts.
Um, I would consider this area here as my broad point of interest.
I would consider this area here as my, quote, unquote, strong point of interest
.
And play.
Okay.
London sweeps Asia.
Into a strong point of interest and gives us a lot of timeframe shift.
So that for me would be my entry confirmation.
Now I need to try to find an entry.
For me in this scenario, I would be looking at this area as my entry.
Again, I'll set it up, but I won't take it until it starts coming towards our
entry level.
That's 3.5 pips.
Um, again, this entire trade again is 13 rich reward, but we're going to be
looking at
a harsh one. Um, again, I'll cover this stuff that we get tagged into the trade
.
So we'll see if the moment that price starts kind of coming towards our entry
level,
we can get that indicates reversal.
Okay.
I'm going to place the trade order is going to be, sorry, cell advanced order,
1% risk.
Cool.
That's our, cancel that.
Okay, let's try that again.
Order cell 1%, okay, sometimes it does this.
Okay, shorts on here.
Stops here.
Okay, that would be my technical.
Okay, 1% limit.
Okay, that would be the, the trade.
And then from management perspective, I didn't actually add that.
So if we're going to here, it's going to be my first target.
Any other areas that I think that price would trade through?
No, not really.
So just two targets for this.
Cool, play price.
Oh, I thought it would come back.
355 still have time.
Again, none of this really matters for me.
Like if we're trading lower, there's still this entire price range is unmet
igated.
So for me, this, it remains where the entry is.
Um, 435.
Okay, so we've been tagged in at 455.
So five minutes before London in session close is fine.
It's kind of continued playing price.
And that would be a stop loss for me.
All right, so that's stopped.
Um, and then again, we just want to be looking at journaling this trade.
So if I move this now, I'll go into journal trade notes.
This is playbook.
So M 15 pro trend.
Yes, strong point of interest or session liquidity.
Sweet.
Well, London sweeps Asia plus run a strong point of interest.
So we have both M one changes character.
Yes, it does.
M one or M five.
I got yes.
Uh, we broke the protected high.
Yes, no trading on session CPI.
Don't end in the trade.
Cool.
So playbook followed.
Now, let's tag this.
So what set up is this?
This is a London sweep Asia.
The point of interest is a strong point of interest.
It is London session.
The trend for the M 15 is, um, let's have a look change of character.
Pullback continuation.
So this is going to be a confirmed reversal.
The structure flow for this specific trade is internally bullish.
So we are internal counter trend.
Right.
So we're internally against the delivery.
We're expecting lower prices, but the internally is actually bullish.
Uh, yeah, we are in premium discount, uh, news, no news and execution window.
This is again, four to five AM.
And yeah, that's tagged.
So that's organized.
So we're keeping moving on to the next trade.
Now, as you can see, New York session is just opened.
We have no news in New York session.
So we could potentially look at trading this as well.
So you can see the sweep on these highs here.
So we have that low that are swept.
So we'll kind of just play 15 minute.
Okay.
I go in here, where is our.
Where is our structure?
So we had lower, low, no, no.
Cool.
So it's.
Is that a change of character?
Yeah.
Cool.
So we're bullish on the M one and the swing low at this moment in time.
It's all the way down here.
Pretty simple, just with three price action.
Okay, we break structure.
So what you can see here is we low, high, high, high, low, high, high.
So the structure moves.
To here, plain and simple.
Okay.
Does that give a three kind of work?
So I want to start from the highest one, which is here.
So one candle.
No, two candles.
So that's not a pullback.
Nor is that.
Still not a pullback.
Okay.
Is that, is that a pullback?
Nope.
Our left of session price respects the low that we needed to see break.
Price breaks the low.
So now we could be looking at a trade.
So what we have here is, essentially, we look at things.
You can see price puts in a high leg, puts in a low, pulls back, breaks the low
.
This week here mitigates this old.
Still have this inverted for the gap, which I'm not a huge fan of leaving that
unmitigated three minute time frame and then one minute.
Cool.
So what I want to look at really is this, the level of price that moves here.
Short position.
Put my stop plus here.
Not a huge fan of my stop placement, but we'll move.
Still protecting this level.
Again, that would be the entirety of the of the move.
So we should go ahead and place that.
And again, I'm just risking 1% of the current balance at all times.
So that would be the position.
Not a huge fan of the stop placement, but we'll trade it and we get taken
straight out.
I think.
Well, not yet.
OK.
See that?
Yeah, OK.
So that break of that low, maybe it's a close on them one.
It's not technically.
And stops.
So I can't move myself to break you in because that doesn't close that low
there for me.
Yeah, that's just a rule of it.
If this did break, I might start would have been up here.
Would have made some of my risk, but still nonetheless.
That counts as a loss for me.
So again, same thing.
Need to general up trade notes.
This is the fourth trade.
Look at our playbook.
So what would be M15 pro trend?
Yeah, we were looking for shorts.
In an M15 bearish market, right?
Cool, strong point of interest or session sweep.
We have the session sweep.
So yeah, we sweep across London session.
Hi, and one change of character.
Yeah, and one order block or point of interest.
We have that here, a break of the protected low or high.
Yes.
And then no trading, no, don't end up before retail.
No, so that's my playbook.
Now, if we tag this trade, this set up would be a.
I would really consider this New York sweep London.
Actually, this is in New York sweep's London point of interest.
Are we trading from a point of interest right now?
Yep, we're trading from a strong point of interest.
Cool session is New York.
The trend is still the same trend.
It's confirm reversal structure flow.
We're still in town or counter trend, premium discount.
Yep, news, no news execution window.
So we get executed.
What time do we get executed this position?
940.
So that's on nine to 10 a.m.
Execution window.
Again, I did say not a huge fan of my stock placement.
Um, yeah, it doesn't really support the high offices, but having extended the
stock all the way up to here.
I'm going to give me the rest of the water out and whatever would have been
great.
Yeah, that's totally fine.
I'm OK with that.
So tags closed.
Cool, that's that session done.
So we'll move to start of London session.
You see, we come to that fair value.
I've had that real aggressive reaction, which is unsurprising 1045.
We still didn't have anything now.
It's the eighth of February.
So eight for fair, no news.
Um, yeah, still no news.
So we keep the ball moving.
Again, what we'll see now is a sweep of this high.
So it looks like we could be heading our way towards bullish price action.
Um, we'll see what happens during this New York, uh, London session.
So we sweep page a high.
OK.
So give us a little time from confirmation.
Uh, no.
Technically already bearish.
M one is already bearish, right?
See, M one is actually already bearish right now.
Um, that's a sweep.
So we can break this law and just continue in this direction.
I'll be OK to trade that.
That's a, that's a continuation.
I'll be more than fine to trade that.
So area of interest, again, I'm really just interested in the bulk of orders.
So this is where the liquidity sweep happens.
And this is where the majority of the volume comes in.
And so this is where I'd be looking to enter the trade.
That's simple, really.
And then protect that high.
So again, this is obviously the end target.
I'm not 100% sure that price is going to reach all the way down there,
but we're going to take partials anyway.
Uh, 1% of current balance.
That would be myself.
And this is two 45.
So we're good.
That's a tag.
OK, that's, that's a continuation.
So I'm 15, I'm 5, I'm 3, I'm 1.
Yeah, I would look at bringing stops to break even.
We'll read the requirements for a break even.
So that would be stops to break even for me.
Um, what I do want to see is where one to five risk reward is.
Because I want to close if we reach on a close it there.
Not close all of it, but at least close some of it.
Cool.
That's my one to five.
You see how price continues here, come back here.
Very close to break even and then take a break even.
Cool.
No problem.
That for me, a valid break even again, journal, trade notes.
When I look at this playbook, M 15 pro train.
Yes.
M one break a short chart.
Yeah.
So that's my break even role and then no news.
So that's my playbook, followed the plan tags.
This is a London sweep Asia.
This is a point of interest.
Uh, we're not actually coming from a point of interest now, because we've
already swept the.
Uh, invalid.
So that would be an invalid trade.
Why?
Because this is my swing high.
Now I was looking at it from the wrong standpoint.
We were liquidated, but then we actually come back here and then we close above
it.
So at that point, it is confirmed change of character.
So I'm actually not following my playbook.
Again, this is the importance of why we need to make sure that we actually have
our
playbook here, because now I can go into this trade.
I go to my playbook and actually say we wasn't M 15 pro trend, right?
So obviously fortunately in this scenario, it ends up being a break even.
But we wasn't M 15 pro trend.
So that is an invalid trade.
Um, and then none of these steps actually makes sense anymore.
There's no text place because it's an invalid trade.
Um, so yeah, you can either, you can have a unselect this, or I mean,
technically,
you can replay yourself and make sure that you don't execute that trade.
So if this is the trade here, it's going to make sure that I don't, I'm not out
.
But now execute that trade and we're cheating yourself in backtesting.
Um, but yeah, obviously this is an invalid trade.
So it no longer makes sense for me to like a trade in that.
But I could trade though is long position.
So if we sweep these lows in here, like we have done and if we get a lower
timeframe
reversal, I could look at trading along.
So that's not a reversal.
Okay.
So it's going to be up here.
The time is this four or two.
Probably not going to get this out, probably.
And no, all right.
It's already too late.
Cool.
New York's ash.
Let's see what New York can give.
So New York session is opening below London session.
We are bullish.
So we're opening below London session.
So we're bullish.
We're looking for longs, kind of see how price is going to deliver itself.
Okay.
Is that a pullback?
Nope.
Ready to see how this timeframe.
I can just look at the 15 minutes timeframe.
Okay, nice.
We can look at either.
Okay.
Is that an M1 shift?
It could be.
No, it's not.
And we continue lower prices.
Time is this 9.5.
Still nothing.
We're not going to get tagged into this trade.
It's not going to happen in time.
And yeah, already too late.
So London session next day.
So we're still bullish, right?
We're still bullish.
We have Asia session low down here.
Cool.
A lot of buy side liquidity as well, but that's different level of context.
This is just playbook oriented.
So we're not looking for longs, shorts only.
Create equal lows.
We sweep that level and that's that session done.
So no set up here, but if we go to New York session, you see, we've already
swept those
lows, so that low, that low, that New York London low phase has indeed sweep
London lows.
The M1 structure.
Let's just get clear on M1 structure for a hot second.
Does indeed break down here.
That's a pullback.
It's a new nation pullback.
So we've changed character.
So the M1 order flow is now bullish.
So what I need to see in New York is a pullback and continuation.
So that is a pull that is a continuation, but it doesn't give us a three kind
of pullback.
So it's not a structural continuation.
And that right there would be a pullback and continuation.
But now you need to find the entry point.
This way I think it's a little bit confusing sometimes because as you can see
on the
five minute timeframe, there's nothing crystal clear in here.
Sorry, it's a knife of February.
Do we have any news?
I forgot that we skipped today.
We still have no news.
So this is where things get a little bit kind of nuanced because there's no
real
specific area of interest here.
So it's up to you.
You can avoid the trade or maybe sometimes you can go to a 15 minute timeframe
and look
on the 15 minute.
And for example, like here in the 15 minute wide, what I objectively identify
is this
is the cluster, right?
So this area in here is the area that the order stack can happen.
And then we had the sell off and I can refine that if I want and I can
bring it down to this final area in here where the volume come in and I can
literally
just use this specific area of price.
So and then I can cover this low and on the 50 on the five minute, what is this
?
It's more of an order block, I guess, bearish move for a bullish move.
So it's still technically an M5 order block.
It's just easier to spot on the 15 minute.
And our profit target is going to be these highs at 4.31.
So this like that, that right there would be the trade.
So we're expecting price to trade a little bit higher than this, which is fine.
But that one to five risk reward, um, that would be myself.
You could again, play how you want.
Like if, if you think it's worth maybe bringing your stops up to here so that
you
can then bring your take profit down to here and make that swing high one to
five.
That's also completely fine.
All right, uh, by limit 1% current balance.
So currently in drawdown, we're about just under 3% down.
That'll be my trade.
So New York session, we get tagged in.
Stops hold and we move straight to take profit.
Eight 30 Friday nights a sip.
That looks like a news event.
Friday, nine for February, eight 30.
It's also most Fridays have news events.
What news was there Friday night?
So you also have to be a little bit careful of trading view.
Because although it does give the majority Friday night for Feb, what's that
going to be?
Okay.
And I have no idea why trading view is not showing up.
How could trading not show that?
Core inflation rate, 13 for Feb.
Apparently nothing.
I don't know.
Yeah, that's just a eight AM candle.
It's very weird though at eight 30 AM exactly have such a spike like that.
But I mean, according to what I'm looking for, it is nothing.
No, so that's valid.
Like if there was no news, that's why I would be that's the position I would be
taken and according to everything.
There is no news, but yeah, that's the position ended up getting quite
fortunate
with that stop placement, although again, even if the stop placement was below
this low and the one to five was here still hits.
So again, this is where the kind of intricate nuance details come up to you.
Now you'll notice I didn't use this exact low.
And if I did, I would have been in trouble because I would have got
stops out there.
I actually used I actually just made it five all.
So in some sense, fortunate, right?
Again, sometimes you're going to have positions where narrowly taps you up
because you stop placement.
Sometimes it might just favor you.
Yeah, quite fortunate.
In most cases, in an ideal world, you've probably seen it in risk management.
In, yeah, management anyway, in an ideal world, I want to have my stops
protected below this law as much as possible.
But yeah, again, let's kind of journal that sort of details.
No journal, cool trade notes.
You're alongs playbooks.
So are we M 15 pro trend?
Yes, we are, right?
Are we, do we have a strong sweep?
Do we have a strong point of interest or session sweep?
Yes, we did.
Right.
We also, we have a strong point of interest in here.
This for me is, um, this for me is still a strong point of interest.
I still leave.
So break, we have internal structure, low, high, lower, low, and then break
through this level, internal pullback shift.
Does that break?
I only wicks.
So it's not actually really how you want this area of interest for me.
Mm, we can see what I consider this stronger week.
So that's internally bullish and then we load up and then we continue.
So it's not completely playbook clear in terms of definition of this in a
strong or weak perspective.
The definition of something being strong is that it breaks something, um,
but the break happens before, but it's part of the price leg.
You know what I mean?
Like this entire price leg is what breaks this low, then we load up in here.
We'll consider it weak.
We'll say it weeks.
It doesn't subject objectively break something.
Uh, yeah, yeah, close half the position at five.
So I didn't actually need to.
Um, again, I'll just, I'll take it because I still followed my rules,
but I didn't need to close the full, uh, half because it was the full
take profit scale out at structural levels.
Yes, no trade and there was no news, no, nothing.
Um, so that's, again, followed tags.
So this is a low continuation.
So the sweep of liquidity comes in the law session, which is the period
between London and New York, we have a change of character and then New York
pretty much just continues that bullish trend.
So it's a low continuation.
Point of interest, um, I'm going to call it a weak point of interest.
Session New York trend, uh, the M 15, uh, sorry.
Yeah, the M 15 trend is in the change of character phase.
The structural flow is actually bullish, uh, internal.
Again, this kind of comes into nuances.
Honestly, if I was to look at this nine times up turn, it wicks the high.
So it's technically not a break, but from an internal perspective.
I would still be looking at that as if I were trading this objective myself.
I'll be looking at this as a pullback continuation shift.
So I was still considered this as, um, counter internal premium and discount.
So we actually traded from the premium discount.
Um, no.
It's just a high, this is a low, there's no way that's in.
Let me just make triple check, but I'm pretty sad it's not.
Nope.
Uh, news, no news execution window.
It was, I got executed, uh, I think just before eight.
Seventh, uh, yeah.
So that's the seven to eight, uh, um, execution window.
Yeah.
That's pretty much it.
And then just keep the ball rolling.
Let's go to London session next day.
So you can see we continued up.
Oh, that kind of did close a little bit higher.
Yeah.
No more price delivery.
Uh, now we're into Monday.
So a fresh week.
Let's check.
Do we have any news?
Nope.
Okay, I'm going to kind of start speeding things up a little bit.
It's already an hour into a quarter.
I'll just kind of play you out as I need to.
So we're bullish.
We had a pull back.
We continued.
So we're bullish.
So I'm looking for long positions.
That's equal lows.
That's now our structural law.
Dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb.
So we're bearish now.
The M 15 is.
Technically bearish.
And I think.
London session.
Cool.
So we are technically bearish in here.
You can see we go low one bullish candle that wicks it one
bullish candle to bullish candle.
So you know, pull back.
No pullback.
Cool.
So we're still bearish.
Age of session happened here.
This is a weak point of interest.
That's the sweep.
That's the shift.
So age of session gets swept in London.
That's not a three kind of pullback.
That is a three kind of pullback.
But is this a structural law?
Let's have a look.
Let's have a look, shall we?
Cool.
Yup.
She's bullish here.
Yeah, it is.
So that is our change of character.
So now we're looking at entries.
All right, here we are, M5.
Again, you can see that this old area has been mitigated, M3, M1.
Cool.
So this area has been mitigated.
We come back, we shift here.
So that's really my area of interest.
My point of interest is you.
What time are we on 245?
So shorts.
I'm looking at this level here.
My stop placement, again.
Let's see, where's the structural law here?
So structural law, that's only a two risk reward.
So the risk reward doesn't really make sense.
But if we can extend it,
I would need price to come down to this low, which we can do.
And again, although it technically we shift the highs here,
we may just be part of this one.
Huge bearish move to go all the way down to these lows.
That's also definitely possible.
So yeah, we could make that.
So what are we, Tuesday 13th of Feb at 245?
So Tuesday, Tuesday 13th of Feb,
we have economic sentiment at five, and then we have CPI.
So I have CPI today in New York session.
So we can trade this, but only in London session.
So order, sell 1%.
So we're currently up 2% after that win.
And yeah, that would be my position.
One to five risk reward, price gets tagged in.
Respect, okay.
So we break the lows.
So it could go to break even.
However, this is still unmitigated.
M3 also, so I'm gonna move my stops here.
And I'm basically gonna shave off a very small amount of risk.
That's essentially what moving my stops there does.
So again, where are we, 335?
At five, we have the ZEW economic sentiment.
So yeah, we need to be cautious of that,
but it shouldn't be too deep.
Cool, continue playing price.
Okay, now the fact that prices come back up
to hear me again this and continued.
Now the area to be respected is this area of supply.
Now I can move my stops to break even.
And that right there would be the adequate
management of break even.
So we have now, we come in to take the swing lows
and obviously I need price to trade
somewhat significantly lower than the swing lows,
but it's possibly a few plain price out
and we get to take that break even.
That's fine.
That's the end of session as well.
So that's the ZEW, which honestly isn't really a big deal.
Good management, good break even management as you can see.
So let's detail that trade notes, shorts, playbook.
And I already know I follow my rules.
Tags, this setup is a London sweep, Asia.
Point of interest.
Am I coming from a point of interest?
I would say so, yeah, but it's more of a weak point of interest.
It's weak because this area didn't break this low.
Session, London trend, what's the current state of the trend?
Change of character, right?
Structural flow.
Internally bullish.
I would say, yeah, we're counter trending tunnel.
Premium discount.
Possibly, but I don't think so.
So we're here, right?
It's the swing low, swing high.
Yeah, we're not in premium discount.
Nope.
News, no news, execution.
Two 45s, that's two to three AM.
And that's my organization.
Now we can move on.
So I'm not even going to bother with New York session
because they have CPI, it's just a straight up miss for me.
So New York session, London session, and that's what CPI did.
Yeah, so again, still respective of structure in a really nice way.
As you can see, that's our point of interest.
That's the mitigation, the continuation, like that's.
No such thing as accidents from one internal range pocket to this area.
This is why this is a weak point of interest as well.
Cool. So now we have liquidity across these lows.
We're bearish now.
So, yeah, we're not really in much of a position to long price.
My expectations that price will probably come back, at least into this range.
This isn't really no man's land.
But yeah, we'll kind of see nonetheless how price plays out.
Let's see.
So we have, do we have news today?
Wednesday, the fourteenths.
We do not.
Cool. So we sweep Asia, right?
Asia has been swept by Frankfurt.
I don't think there's any structure, actually.
Is that three going to pull back?
No.
So there's nothing to play here.
Plain and simple.
In this context as well, sometimes you'll see me go internal.
So we have that sweep, but it becomes a case of one-minute structure.
Can already see that it's probably not a one-minute structure level.
Is there?
No pullback, no pullback, and then pullback, but we don't break, right?
Or do we? No, equalize.
So our one-minute structure is all the way up here, so we're down here.
Now, in these scenarios, when you have this really aggressive structure,
you can opt in for going internal.
So if I take a position based off of the internal structure, that is still
discretion.
But yeah, the very definition of discretion really just always is structural.
So we can mark this discretion if it plays out.
Let's see. Is there an internal shift?
At least there must be.
You can't get that price action without an internal shift.
Yeah, so you can see there's a huge internal shift, right?
And the real internal shift comes here.
So again, there's no possibility for me to play external M1.
So I can play internal, if necessary.
But if I'm going to do that, it's going to have to go down as a discretionary
setup.
So at least at the end, we'll understand discretion versus, you know, reality.
We sweep in Frankfurt.
We get the change of character in Frankfurt.
That's not our continuation.
So I need to see London play a continuation.
If London breaks the lows, the reality of London breaking these lows
and not taking this low and getting in, it's just not going to happen.
So it's probably not going to be a trade here.
Oh, that's a work.
That's a work.
Okay, that's a break.
Okay, cool.
So we're technically bearish.
Now the issue is, is I don't like the fact that we have,
we've confirmed that price is going to lower, but we have equal highs here.
We have a fair value gap.
We have an M15 point of interest.
Like if it's me, this is where we'll be looking at trading from.
How large is the stop size, 4.4 pips.
One to five is much lower, passive slow, but we are extremely bearish
and delicious playing continuations.
Again, I'll execute, but I'll just put down a discretion and at least at the
end,
my discretion either hinders the results or helps the results,
but the results will be filtered by discretion and objectivity.
250.
There's already the sweep of these lies.
Again, you can play this differently as well.
Could tag straight away or could wait on the one minute time frame for a lower
time frame shift,
but there's no area for a shift.
That's a break even, but I can't go to break even.
I'm going to have to bring my stops.
Slightly above this high.
So I've managed to reduce some of my risk, but not the full
amount.
Don't like this build up in here.
We'll see how this plays out.
If we break these highs, I will let it go and break even.
And again, that's my, this is discretion, so I can do that.
If we break these highs, I'm going to break even.
Yeah, it's highly likely that this trade will go to break even.
Yep.
Again, could have tried to manage this differently, but even the fact that it
is
actually a discretionary trade, like I've entered this trade based off of
discretion, I guess, in some sense.
It just makes more sense for me to manage a discretionary as well.
So the trade makes sense for me.
The profit target, obviously, you can only do what I can do.
But we'll know it anyway, and we'll know it as a discretionary trade.
At least you can also get into my mind and understand how I'm reading price as
well.
So playbook.
So M15 was pro trend, strong point of interest, or social liquidity, it was.
M1 change character, no, yes, yes, no, technically not.
And yes.
So follow the five out of seven, not just a complete gamble.
You can see I followed five out of seven.
This setup, again, isn't really any setup.
So I'm going to leave all these tags empty.
I don't want to distort the data of the tags.
So yeah, it's because it's not set up technically.
Cool.
So we'll come out here.
It's key price going.
So now we're in New York session.
Honestly, I'm probably expecting price to trade higher.
Oh, wait.
The low goes here, it's three candles.
Okay.
So we're already just, we've just shifted bullish.
I think it's even higher prices anyway.
Okay.
Oh, nothing for me there.
London session.
I know I'm running like, we're almost 90 minutes.
Thursday, 15th, February, and I'm only half of it for the week.
A month.
So I'm going to kind of speed things up a little bit.
What do we have here?
We have retail sales at eight though.
So I want to be avoiding that really.
We're bullish.
Plain and simple with bullish.
I'm looking for longs.
It's that simple.
Okay.
Now what happens is age low becomes swing low.
I'm no longer interested.
Not interested.
And then at eighth or eight,
we have retail sales also not interested.
Cool.
That's that session done.
We're not getting anything.
Let's keep the ball rolling.
We're obviously bearish.
Now we're in this kind of broad POI.
In fact, I would say that we're now in the strong POI.
So we're now inside of this strong point of interest as well.
So the day is Thursday, 15th for Feb.
Oh wait.
No, it's a 16th Friday.
So it is Friday, the 16th for Feb.
We have building permits not bothered about PPI,
not bothered about Michigan consumer sentiment at 10.
Yeah, not a huge, not a huge deal.
All right, let's keep playing price.
Looking for longs again.
Wait, am I?
Sorry.
Yeah, look at the longs.
In some sense, also think that price could definitely trade lower.
But I'm playing purely based off of objective playbook here.
So look at the longs.
I want to see these Asian levels get shorted.
I get swept.
Okay, we don't get that.
And then what's that?
PPI.
Must be PPI.
Yeah, it is.
It's not building permits.
Yeah, that must have been from PPI.
Okay, produces price index.
Okay.
Didn't expect such an aggressive move from PPI to be honest with you.
But that, I mean, you could take longs off the back of it,
but there's not going to be a, there's not going to be a lower time frame
confirmation.
Again, could result to internal, but honestly, just be discretion.
And so what's the point?
Let's just play the actual playbook.
A London session.
So we're still bearish.
No, sorry.
Economy.
We're not still bearish.
Still bullish.
That was a swing high.
That goes into this here.
And we have a pullback.
Then we break structure.
So we're at the premium of price right now.
So we're probably not going to get a trade.
Hmm, I already missed it.
No shift in London.
I already missed it.
Doesn't matter.
Let's go to New York.
Okay.
New York's here.
We technically do have, is that a swing come after London?
Technically, a sweep of London.
I really don't like it objectively.
But this is still technically a sweep of London.
On the one minute timeframe, we have no change of character.
So the actual change of character would have to come all the way up here.
So if New York can break that high, then we can long.
We're not going to get a trade.
Nope, done.
That's the change of character.
So at that point price becomes bearish.
We could look at short and if we can sweep on this high into this area of
interest.
Nope.
Cool.
Oh good.
Start up London session.
Let's see what we got.
Let's go to all these drawings.
So.
London, London, sweep of highs.
Change of character with bearish.
With bearish, I'm more above Asia.
So I'm looking for shorts.
I like that we're in this high as well.
So I'm looking for shorts plain and simple.
M1 has Frank first shifted bearish.
This is one of those where I'd have to go to internal.
Because the price leg is pretty much the same.
I would have to go to internal.
We can go to internal.
We just label it as discretionary.
In fact, what I'm going to do is when I take a trade that's discretionary,
I'm going to give the logic behind it so that when we get the data at the end,
we can go through and trade it with discretionary and understand what it was.
And if that rule, if that rule is profitable.
So for example, right now, I'm taking discretion.
And the reason is discretionary.
Is because I'm taking a trade off of internal one minute structure instead of
external.
Because the external is so large that it physically doesn't make possible.
It doesn't make sense to take the trade based off of.
Based off of M1 external.
So I'm going to use the M1 internal.
And I'm going to label it discretion, but I'll add the notes.
So we know that we're bearish.
We shift bearish at this low here, but we can't take the trade yet.
We need to see a continuation.
In New York session.
So let's see if we get a continuation.
We don't.
Okay, cool.
Do we get a reversal?
That's not.
That is.
So technically,
we'll look at trading this.
M5. Don't like the equal highs.
Rest reward is low.
One to five, what do you price a couple of word on here?
I'll take it, but it's still considered discretionary.
I will go sell.
What a great.
Cool.
What time is it?
250, we've got time.
And straight up.
So let's journal this.
Let's make sure that we understand that this was.
Just so I understand.
Playbook, we were in 15 Pro trend.
Yes.
No.
Yes, yes, yes.
So again, the only thing is we didn't have the change of character.
I'm going to start tagging the description I want as well.
So we can start seeing it.
I'm already always an awkward idea.
I'm not going to attack them.
Again, I'm doing an all of this just live.
Like, I'm just, I'm basically just back testing myself.
And you're just kind of watching me do it.
We'll go to New York session, see London, see Rocket and I didn't check news
again.
20th, it's all clear.
So we're all good.
Cool.
So that puts a spin on things.
Because now we shift bullish.
New York pulled back, no continues, no trade.
Next day, 21st.
Do we have, we have FOMC.
So I want to be very cautionary.
We might get low volatility anyway.
Um, I could look at longs for sure.
And now I bearish.
There's not going to be a trade.
And then New York, I'm not interested in trading New York purely by self about
the FOMC is coming.
FOMC is already being, and it didn't really even do anything.
But yeah, on a different day, you don't know what's going to be said.
Um, cool.
So yeah, there also wouldn't have been a trade technically.
We go again, London session continued in that same bullish direction.
Again, sometimes that's just how it goes.
Like you mark out these as your swing structure and the market wants to adhere
to this being your swing structure.
Nothing you can do about it.
Just again.
So are we bullish yet?
So we're not bullish yet, but we're about to be.
And we're bullish.
Probably not going to get trade here either.
Again, at this point, just kind of kind of see it.
This is 22nd. Uh, do we have any news we have?
Dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum.
Nothing.
Just H cop, which is, I'm already bothered about it.
It may give a reaction, to be honest with you.
Um, yeah, it may give a reaction.
Yes, we honestly make a reaction.
H cop is something that typically does anything you're related.
It's usually H cop.
That's it.
So not that deep.
But yeah, we're extremely bullish.
Like for me to get into trade now.
In New York, probably very unlikely price going to have to come all the way
down here.
And then do this.
And then like, yeah, that's what would have to happen.
Um, I can probably just get to New York to be honest with you.
New York.
Okay, this is the territory that I would want to be.
And if I'm looking for longs.
Um.
Yeah, we've taken Asia low.
This will be on New York, sweet Asia.
If we get the set up, what time is it?
915, probably not going to get a trade.
Um, let's see, how much structure?
Oh, that's technically, that's fine.
Oh, we may get a trade.
That's not.
Yeah, 942.
Hmm.
Okay, 15 minutes.
Okay.
We can try that.
Longs.
We're longs here pretty much.
Stops at these lows.
Um, where's our one to five?
One to fives all the way at the swing highs up in here.
Is there a way to one to six?
Let's see.
Maybe we'll refine this a little bit.
Maybe we'll put about the actual order block itself.
So we're going to pure order block.
Cool.
So that becomes one to seven.
So we can place that.
Um, order 1% risk.
Okay, we'll place that.
Where's one to five?
One to five.
At Asia, at London, New York, I guess.
So if we get here, we can close 50%.
Or the lights close 50% of these highs.
And then the rest of the position goes into here.
Let's see if we get attacked.
What's this?
945.
Straight type.
Is that a break here?
Okay.
Well, it doesn't look right.
Hmm.
It's 20 seconds left.
Do we have any news?
We don't.
Okay.
Break even above these highs.
There's nothing unmeagated now.
So if we can break those.
Hmm, okay.
This is still technically unmeagated.
Let's see.
It must stops here.
See if we run.
If we start running, we can move our stops to break even.
Because again, the purpose of break even is
no need to come back to that level to continue.
Oh, that's the mitigation.
We can now officially move to break even.
Because now there's really no need to come back.
It's really break even.
Um, yeah, cool.
Let's just see.
Okay, we're moving into Southside 22nd.
This is an Asia session.
This is okay.
We're still in the same trade.
Are we looking for longs?
We're still looking for longs.
I could be scaling into this position here.
Hold on a second.
We bullish.
Asia low.
Sweet by Frank for one minute time frame.
Okay, this would technically be the break.
If we break this now or if we have broke it.
Then we could play.
Not a huge fan of it, but we're already in a position.
So we have broke it.
M5 area area that we can look at trading from.
There's nothing that's super clean.
M3, M1.
I mean there's a fair value gap down here.
Where do I put my stops?
Because I don't want to get stopped out.
I put my stop plus here.
Where's one to five?
Oh yeah, we could play that.
For sure.
Okay, well the actual target's up here.
So order by.
And then one to five is.
Here.
So we could partial at that level.
Okay, we'll just see how it goes.
Make sure it's filled these positions and individually.
If that even gets tagged.
It does get tagged.
And it gets stopped out.
And oh no.
Okay, I need to journal that real quick.
So that gets journaled.
Trade now.
Okay, which one is it?
I don't know.
94 29.
Okay, let's have a look.
So is this already been tagged?
No, which means that must be this one.
But I need to make sure.
But it must be.
Yeah, it would have to be.
Oh yeah, of course it already says here.
There's a lot.
94.
Okay, cool.
So this is the first long.
We don't know what the outcome of that is yet.
Probably going to be a break.
Even second long.
Play, but we are in 15 pro trend.
We have a sweep of liquidity, which is.
Asia.
We have all of this.
The tags is where it gets interesting because this is.
A Frankfurt.
Frankfurt.
No, it's not a Frankfurt sweep.
No, it is a Frankfurt sweep.
Frankfurt sweep.
Yeah, Frankfurt sweep reversal.
Frankfurt sweeps Asia and reverse.
So Frankfurt sweep reversal.
Point of interest.
We don't have one.
I really have a point of interest to be honest with you.
Just call it a weak point of interest.
Session is London.
Yeah.
Trend is.
First phase change of character wrote.
Yeah.
Structural flow.
I don't really have any.
Premium discount.
Yes.
Um.
News.
No news.
Execution window.
When we get tagged in.
Between three and four.
Cool.
Oh, we're still in this position.
It's Friday, 23rd.
IFO.
London, New York.
I don't need to see for New York.
There's not really going to be a New York setup.
And that's a break even.
So.
That's break even.
Doesn't make sense to hold that open.
Um, that's a loss.
So where are we currently at?
We're again, pretty much a break even.
So February, 24th does so far.
Pretty much a break even.
Month.
It's going to move all of this.
Oh, this is again just for one model.
Um, let's go to London session.
Monday, 26th of February.
We are still bullish.
Do we have any news?
Don't think so.
26th of February.
We don't actually have any news.
So we're still long.
Some sort of longs.
Nope.
And.
Oh, where was our break even?
Damn it.
Our break even was like here.
Sometimes that's just the way the country crumbles.
Um, still nothing for long, so.
Cool.
I said as well, I wanted this area as my area of profit.
Such a nice liquidity area.
Tuesday, London session.
Do we have any news?
We do.
We have durable goods.
At eight thirty and we have G of K consumer confidence.
So we're still long.
We won't be trading that.
So that's that's sweet.
But for me, London, New York session is already finished.
Has could trade longs if we get confirmation.
Um.
Nope.
Ah, session done as well.
Next day.
So we are still technically bullish,
although the fact is that we fail to break this high,
which is really not nice.
Um, 28th of February.
So this should be final day, right?
Unless to this year you have 29 days.
Oh, yeah, did 28th of February.
GDP, go for it.
Don't want to be into that.
And then call PC price index.
So we've got heavy news the next couple of days.
Uh, London session.
Nothing.
And then sessions are already finished.
Miss Anderson.
Nope.
Cool.
New York session.
I'm going to really skip the company session,
which is this GDP, go for it.
Okay, that's GDP growth rate.
Okay.
So no sweep.
We sweep this low down here.
And done.
London.
Okay, final day of fab.
This is where we have PC and personal spending.
Still look at the longs.
That could be a long position.
London sweep Asia.
And we are.
Okay, we're bullish.
How does invert favor you go?
One to five is up here.
Hmm.
Ambitious.
What time is it?
320.
We'll go over it.
I've gone for this M5 invert.
If I go.
Dun, dun, dun.
And it's four.
But I guess that's over right.
Yeah.
Cool.
Just missed the tag.
I'm fortunate, but hey, huh?
Let's go to New York session.
So New York session, we do have
some pretty aggressive news.
So we'll see.
Hey, you can see that the momentum is slow.
Okay, there's news.
I could trade off the back of that.
Real nice London session sweep.
Obviously, M1 change of character in here.
If I am not mistaken, I am not mistaken.
I've already skipped it too far.
Have I?
Technically have.
Because I would have traded that.
I would trade.
If I was in this trade, I would trade this.
I have a news at 10.
29 to fit this day.
Wait, do we take a position?
No.
It's kind of a dev on Zepha day.
No, okay, we're cool.
Yeah, an idea of what I'll take that.
I don't know.
Let me replay this for a second.
So this is what it actually looks like.
We do have this over here.
But the real break comes from this order block.
What day is it Thursday?
And tomorrow is going to be the first.
And do we have a news?
I'll take it.
A15, I'll take it.
Bye.
It's audacious in terms of target, but I mean structurally.
At some point.
See how it plays out.
So I know that gets tagged.
At least I can get the break even.
End of New York session.
Let's see.
I would go to break even.
Nothing on me again in the five minute.
How do I break even?
And this is tricky now because this is the end of Feb.
But now we're heading over into March.
Let's see.
Did we get break even?
Yeah, break even.
Cool.
Good management again.
So that's Feb done.
So Feb is pretty much break even.
Like literally pretty much break even.
So I break even months.
For Feb.
Not mad at it.
Sometimes that's just how the cookie grumbles.
I'll go back and talk back to them.
We'll see what we've got so far.
This all of this stuff was introduced later, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
What we can see though is we can see some data.
So we can see is.
If we come in here, don't wait.
Okay.
So far, you can obviously see that we are at break even.
Not great.
Is that us all so far?
Average winter loss ratio is the only thing that's really keeping us alive.
We are pretty much a break even profit factor.
1% of it is really low.
That's a really bad.
That just says a lot though, right?
Like a 16.6% win rate.
And a break even month.
People say it's all the time like, oh, you know,
if you have a month where you have like a 25% win rate,
which they definitely happen with this model.
And you try to ask them, well, you have a 25% win rate.
They're going to tell you that you're crazy and like, don't be wrong.
For me, honestly, my personal opinion, I think this is a bad.
It's a bad month.
No doubt about it, but the fact that on a bad month,
we're still able to break even off of one.
One profitable trade.
We see we have one win and four losses.
So why are we
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6?
Why is there six trades here?
Okay, a break even, that's why.
And I'm assuming this two trades is both losers.
Okay, so it's not.
So it's actually 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So it's five losers.
So why does it show a four?
Why does it show a four losers here?
Ah, day.
Ah, got it.
Cool, it shows five here.
Cool.
Yeah, not great.
So let's have a little look at our data just for this so far.
And then we'll kind of get started with the new February march.
We'll start with March.
This has been like almost two hours.
So I'm going to try and get through March a little bit quicker, but yeah.
Nine trading days, one winning day, four losing days.
Real difficult month.
These are the months where you really have to have your psychology in check.
Let's have a little look at our models.
It's the way to do the dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb.
There's a better way to do this session.
So a little look, sorry, not session.
Cells.
Let's see what cells are doing well so far.
So, so far our only winner was with the law continuation.
Obviously, it's far too insufficient of data to understand this.
This is what we're going to be looking at, the end, right?
When we come to the end, we're going to be looking at our reports.
This is what we're going to do.
We're going to look at our setup.
Some be like, okay, what setups are actually making us money?
And what setups are, you know, not making us money.
Because if we come into here at the end of an entire year's worth of data
collected,
and we can see that one setup is clearly just not making us money,
simply just by removing that setup, you make your system more profitable.
It's not simple.
And you can look at other tags as well.
For example, like, again, it's really too early, but execution window.
We can see that, you know, the 45 AM is not really working too well at the
moment,
but the seven to AM against the only winner, insufficient amount of data.
But just kind of get a little bit of gauge of how it's going to play out.
Okay, cool.
We'll wrap up February.
Let's get into March.
I'll try to make March a little bit quicker.